You can also write at those gates as
multiplying the inputs either by 0,
when the gate is closed, or
by 1, when the gate is open.
That's all fine, but what does it
have to do with neural networks?
Imagine that instead of having
binary decisions at each gate,
you had continuous decisions.
For example, instead of yes-no gate
at the input, you take the input and
multiply it by a value
that's between 0 and 1.
If it's exactly 0, no input comes in.
If it's exactly 1,
you write it entirely to memory.
Anything in between can be
added partially to the memory.
Now that becomes very interesting for
us, because if that multiplicative
factor is a continuous function
that's also differentiable, that
means we can take derivatives of it.
And that also means we can
back propagate through it.
That's exactly what an LSTM is.
We take this simple model of memory,
we replace everything with
continuous functions.
And make that the new Lowell
machine that's at the heart
of a recurrent neural network.